It would be really interesting, I think, if there was a piece of functionality which was like...
Take my scrappy notes and make it beautiful.
Absolutely that, like 100% that.
Alright, we're rolling and today we have Emil from Kaida with us. Welcome, dude.
Hello, hello.
And we've also got the Grinch, apparently.
Joel, show the people your voice right now, man.
Okay, so a child coughed on me on an airplane and it was funny because in the group chat, like I witnessed it happen.
Like I was like sitting there, this child just like open mouth coughed like right next to me.
And I was like in the group chat and I was like, oh, some kid just coughed on me like GG.
And then like four days later, it's like it all hit me.
Dude, I saw that message too and I was like, oh gosh, Joel is being a germaphobe or something like that.
And here we are with the voice.
Well, alright, Joel, hang in there, man.
If you want to say something, you can say something.
Or feel free to like just message me on Discord or something like that if you want me to say something instead and spare the listeners ears.
But yeah, we'll figure it out.
Yeah, it's bare my throat as well.
Yeah, well that's true.
That as well.
But we'll figure it out one way or another.
Emile, man, so I've had the pleasure of meeting you a couple times, but never in person.
Just visual over the chat.
Yeah.
And I'm actually more familiar with Kaido through Ian.
Because I've worked with him at the live hacking events before.
Yeah.
So why don't you give me a little bit of an intro to you and how you ended up in this crazy world of writing an HTTP proxy for a very specific set of customers.
Yeah, that's a pretty crazy adventure.
So basically, Ian is my friend from high school.
We went kind of our separate ways after high school.
He went to different universities than me.
So I did a bunch of during the university and after that, I did a bunch more on the development side.
So infrastructure work for AWS, mainly a bit of GCP and development work also.
And then I was in between contracts like two years and a half ago.
And then he just asked me basically, I'm working on this cool new projects.
Do you want to participate on it?
And I always wanted to start a company personally.
I was doing consulting, but starting a business is different from just the service work.
So I jumped on the idea and here we are two years later.
So Ian just says, you know, hey man, you up, you know, and says, hey, you want to start a company?
And it just happened like that, huh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And at some point I'm going to share like the screenshots of what it looked like.
And you would not believe it.
Like, eh.
Oh my gosh, man.
That's crazy.
It was the light theme.
So I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, light theme.
The eyes.
No, but that's really cool, man, that you jumped on that opportunity.
And I know, I know just from talking to Ian, Ian is the other co-founder of Kaido.
For those of you that are not familiar with the company.
Well, you will be familiar with the company by the end of this episode.
So hang in there.
But yeah, man, you know, Ian has always said it's been a pleasure working with you and I'm
glad he's got a partner in this challenge because I, you know, I've been talking with
him a little bit and I've seen y'all's company develop over the past couple of years.
And it's a lot of work, man.
There's a lot of feet, you know, in the beginning.
When we, when we were all just kind of at the live hacking events being like, man, I really
don't like burp, you know, and we have this conversation at the live hacking events a lot
because, um, you're on your laptop, right?
Yeah.
And, and when you're at home, you know, you've got your desktop and the desktops are a little
bit more chunky and they can handle it.
But when you're at the live hacking event and you're like on the verge of finding a cool
bug or something like that, and then you burp just kind of craps out on you.
It's the worst.
So, you know, we, we were always talking about, you know, what it would look like to build another,
another HTTP proxy tool.
Um, but as you guys are taking it on, there are a lot of features that, that we've all
sort of taken for granted.
Right.
Definitely.
Yeah, definitely.
I think like the basic, we got pretty fast, but then after that it's all the settings and
all the small things that one person uses, but like not everybody else that kind of piles
up on top of it.
So, and so, yeah.
Have you guys, let me ask this.
Have you guys, um, have you guys been, how have you balanced trying to get everyone able
to use the product for their basic needs?
You know, just basic HTTP proxy versus implementing some of these nice to haves that we are used
to using in burp or other HTTP proxy tools.
Yeah.
I think it goes a lot with the, the GitHub issues.
We've relied a lot on that to determine which features is really important.
We also have like obviously business priorities and all of that, but we do lean a lot on that,
uh, based on like upvotes and how, how much people talk about them in general.
Um, so it's been kind of our strategy.
It's not easy because like, there are some stuff that we know people want for a long time,
like plugins and we can come back to that.
Uh, but they are harder also.
So we have to balance also what, how much we can ship and we want to do a release almost
every month or something like that.
So to respect that timeline, we also have to like choose pick and choose what we work on.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
And that's one of the things I, you know, we've talked about Kaido plenty of times and every
time we talk about Kaido on this podcast, for some reason, somebody comes under the video
and even though it's in the description, they say, and they had a comment, Hey, how do you
spell Kaido?
I can't find it.
It's C A I D O.
Everyone just, I'm just going to go ahead and just put that out there right now.
So C A I D O Google it.
Um, it's an awesome tool.
And one of the main things that I've really appreciated about the past couple of years of
using this tool is that you guys have been, um, working off of those GitHub issues, right?
Just like you said, so we have a lot of ability to influence the development of the tool.
Yeah.
So if you have some really great feature that you would really like, you can, you know,
if you and a bunch of other people agree that this is a really great feature, you can get
that implemented or if a bug is happening, it gets fixed very quickly.
So I I've been, I've benefited firsthand from that, that process.
So thanks for, thanks for sticking to that.
We have some of our special users that we like to please more.
You know, you know, it warms the heart.
It warms the heart.
Um, uh, but yeah, so I guess we sort of jumped the gun cause I got excited, but tell me a
little bit about, for those of you that haven't heard of Kaido, you should go back and listen
to the other episodes of critical thinking where we talk about that all the time.
It's a great podcast.
So thanks man.
Um, but give, give the, give the listeners a quick summary of what, what the primary goals
of the software is and what Kaido is in general.
So like you said, it's a, it's a proxy.
So the goal is to intercept, uh, traffic, HTTP traffic between your browser and your targets.
Um, try to find vulnerabilities, like just give you the most tools we can to like help
you find the vulnerabilities and then replay the traffic, uh, do some brute forcing if you
need to.
Uh, we are starting to like integrate more and more tools as we go along.
So just analyze the traffic and all that we, we are, if you want to modify stuff on the
fly, we have the match and replace rule.
So we try to get as much, uh, tool as you're used to, uh, from, from, uh, from Burp suite
or zap into this, uh, this new projects.
And one of the features that we have that is kind of unique is this client server architecture
where like, you don't need to run Kaido on your laptop.
You can run it remotely.
That's, that's, I think it's a, it's a bit of an education because people are not used
to, to that, to doing that.
Yeah.
Tell the people about that.
Tell them how that you can set that up.
So, so Kaido is, is a server and a client.
It's completely separate.
You can run them on the same machine, but it's a rough server.
So we made it run like on almost every platform you can imagine from raspberry pies to your
VPS in the cloud.
So you run this small CLI on, on the server and then you connect to it via the, your browser,
or we also have a small desktop app.
That's quite lightweight, but, uh, it's basically a web view to, to this server.
And then you connect to that.
And then after that, you proxy your traffic through it.
It's a super easy to do.
And what I like about this architecture is we're not tied to, to a per license model for us.
Like you install Kaido on any device you want.
Like it doesn't matter how many and you just pay once for that.
So, wow.
Yeah.
That's awesome, man.
And I love how that also just very artfully solves the problem.
And you guys are solving it in multiple ways, as you mentioned, because the server is actually
coded in rust, which is a far more efficient language than, than Java is for these sort
of processing tasks.
Um, so you've solved the, you know, overhead problem in that way, but you've also solved it
with this client server architecture.
And I've, I've personally benefited benefited from this a lot because I have a Chromebook
and I really like having this little Chromebook around.
It's very light.
It's really easy to use.
And I have a way to, you know, run Kaido on my server and then connect it up to my Chromebook
and proxy the traffic from the Chromebook through the, through the Kaido server, and then interact
with the, the Kaido UI on the, on the, um, on the Chromebook itself.
Mm-hmm .
And it works, it works great.
Um, and so that was really, I'm, dude, I just, I love it so much.
It just, it just, oh, it's amazing.
Yeah.
We've seen some pretty crazy stuff.
Like people run it on like Android devices, like tablets and stuff like that.
So we've seen that people like one guy was trying to set it up the other day on like,
he had the iPad for the front end and then he has his VPS and was like camping or whatnot.
What the heck?
And he was doing hacking on his iPad.
He was hacking from his iPad.
Yeah.
So.
Jeez, man.
Yeah.
Before you like, I've done that a couple of times in the ways that I've had to do it
was I'd have to connect, you know, before Kaido, I'd have to just use like team view or something
like that to connect back to my main computer.
And then I'm like slowly dragging the cursor around and it's like, no, please.
Yeah.
So that's, that's really cool, man.
Um, yeah.
And it's, it seems like it's been a great, great project so far.
Yeah.
Um, so let me ask you this.
There's, there's, um, you guys have developed it to the point now where you have a lot of
the base features.
You've got the, you know, the HTTP proxy in place.
You guys, uh, have a web socket history in place.
You've got the match and replace stuff.
Um, automate, so like intruder and all that.
Yeah.
Automate.
And, um, so what, what are the, you know, you mentioned the client and server thing already,
but let's give you, let's give you four other things you want to shout out, um, in this
app that people should be aware of as far as features go that could help their day-to-day
testing life.
Yeah.
Well, like, uh, we, we, uh, we discussed that a bit internally also, like what we wanted
to do to discuss, uh, with people.
Yeah.
And I think the overall team is we want to make people more efficient and, and that goes
into many small sections of the app.
So just from like changing projects, like changing, I don't know if you use more projects because
of it, but like,
I do.
Yeah.
Because like,
Because it's just a dropdown and you just select it and boom, it's there.
You don't need to restart anything.
It's, it's in the app.
Yeah.
Uh, and we try to also keep people more organized.
We have this concept of collections and we're going to expand it more with notes related to
collections and all of that.
So that's another thing we, we try to like, it was a nightmare for just keeping your replay
collections or.
Yeah.
Tell me about, okay.
So the collections I've got, I've got kind of open here.
Um, is that if I go here and to replay and then I've got, okay, I can add various thing.
And this allows me to group my various sort of logical entities of the HTTP requests.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
That's the goal.
And what do we found is like, people were like, ah, it's annoying.
You have to like put it in a collection and whatnot.
But at the end of the day, like once, once you go back to your stuff, it's interesting
because like, it is more organized and you can find stuff faster than, than you used to.
So that's our premise.
We try to push, gently push our users to like be more organized.
And I think we're going to add more features like eventually with reporting.
And that's the same philosophy.
We're going to, we're going to take in terms of like keeping you organized as much as possible.
Yeah, no, that's great.
Any tools that will help me along the way with that.
I'm, I'm very grateful for it.
We talk about it on the podcast all the time, but if you, if you talk to all of the top hackers,
um, and you ask them, Hey, like, what is your organization flow or your note taking flow look
like?
Well, they're, they're all like, well, I've got this scratch pad next to my desk.
And like, sometimes I write down every third letter of a request or something.
Yeah.
It's like, or like, I've got like notes.txt.
And then I just literally cat everything into that, you know?
Like, um, and so, you know, we're by nature, we're a very, it seems we're a very disorganized
bunch.
Um, and so this goes part of the creativity you need for like this kind of work.
Right.
So it was like, usually like I'm a bit like that also.
Uh, but, uh, yeah, it's, it's a question of keeping you organized.
Like you need tools, you need strategies for that.
So I think that's kind of our philosophy in terms of, uh, yeah, I remember, I remember very
clearly the first time I found out that you could rename burp tabs and I was like, Oh, this
is amazing.
And, and I think they've implemented maybe, I think you guys actually implemented collections
first.
So maybe this was a response to, to that in burp, but they've added, you know, groups now.
Yeah.
And so, um, you know, this, this is definitely where the industry is moving.
And I think you guys made it, took a great step with that.
Um, and so I, I, it's definitely, uh, takes a second to, to get used to, um, with the,
you know, adding and, and that sort of thing, but that extra layer of organization will really
help.
I think in the long, long run.
Yeah, definitely.
And I think we're, as we build more stuff into it, like that's going to be more present
as we add notes and, and, and things like that.
Uh, yeah.
So, so then you can take notes specifically on individual requests or individual collections
or what?
Yeah.
That's the, that's one of the next goal for, for next year.
Like we want to do the whole reporting and, and just note taking and everything, trying
to, to go further than, than what you currently have.
So, um, nice.
Yeah.
It's giving you a bit of pressure on the notes.
Like I've seen the, they released some stuff.
So, uh, it's going to move up the timeline.
Yeah.
I think it would also really be interesting.
Um, cause you guys have this assistant functionality as well that utilizes, um, chat GPT, right?
Yeah.
We already have that integrated.
And so, you know, if I, if I right click on a request and I, and I, let me see if I do
it from replay and I hit assistant, there's explain and there's generate CSRF POC.
Mm-hmm.
It would be really interesting.
I think if there was a piece of functionality, which was like, uh,
Take my scrappy notes and make it beautiful.
Yeah.
Absolutely that.
Like 100% that, but also, Hey, write a report surrounding this HTTP request.
Right.
Maybe you get to give like a little, like two sentence blob, right on it that says, okay,
this is the primary request that is vulnerable to IDOR.
Mm-hmm.
And then, you know, the LLM just looks at the full request and says, okay, this is probably
what the, and maybe you could even outline like template structures for reports.
Yeah.
And then the LLM would just build it all out.
I think that would be amazing.
Yeah.
It's definitely in, uh, in the work, uh, in our head at least.
Uh, and I think it's going to come like more, uh, next year where we want to expand a lot,
the, the reporting, the more also everything that is from you to like an accurate one, like
doing that connection faster and everything like that.
Uh, and then from them, eventually I also want to be on the other side, uh, as a business owner, I'd like to be on the other side.
So they don't have like, when you submit a report, it's, it's super easy for them to retest.
And if it's, if it's with Kaido, it's even faster or something like that.
Okay.
So you're thinking about like creating some sort of, ah, that would be super helpful because like maybe,
Oh dude, I think I've seen the vision now.
You're seeing the vision.
Yeah.
Okay.
So like now I have my, you know, my, my setup here in, in Kaido and I like, maybe I could generate or take a collection and say, you know, okay,
there's this specific flow of requests in the, in the collection.
Right.
And, and then I export it maybe in the person on their side, just clicks a link and they see, you know, Kaido in their browser for a moment or something like that.
And it walks them through the, the flow.
That's kind of the idea.
Yeah.
Dude.
What the heck?
I'm so hyped for that.
That would, that's going to be amazing.
Yeah.
We have a whole lot of those ideas.
It's just a matter of like, we're three people.
I mentioned like, I don't think you met Chris before.
It's our third partner.
No, I haven't.
So he's a, he's part-time on it, uh, right now.
So, uh, we're only three people and, uh, we do our best.
We ship a lot of stuff for three people, but we still have our limits.
Uh, now Chris, I, I actually haven't heard you mention Chris before.
Is Chris a new partner?
Has he been along from the beginning?
No, he's been, uh, he's been there, uh, since the beginning.
It's just that he has, uh, another job also.
And, uh, sure.
And what kind of, so Ian, I know is doing, uh, well, why don't you tell me a little bit
about the division of duties a little bit?
Yeah.
So Ian is doing all the front end.
So if you like the front end, that's entirely him.
Awesome.
Okay.
Crazy that he, he, he went from like a hacker to.
Bless his heart, man.
Bless his freaking heart.
Yeah.
And, and we don't even have a designer.
So it's kind of crazy.
Cause like.
That is tricky.
Yeah.